uh so republican congressman louis
gomert
from texas one of the wackiest and most
ignorant
members of congress out there has tested
positive for coronavirus now gohmert
has also aggressively refused to wear
masks but he believes
that some brief moment of mask wearing
may actually be what gave him the virus
i'm going to show you that video in a
moment but as a reminder
for months louis gohmert has been seen
on capitol hill
refusing to wear a mask in fact just two
days ago he was at attorney general bill
barr's hearing
and walked out of the room right behind
william barr neither wearing a mask
neither he nor william barr wearing a
mask that is
raising questions about barr's possible
exposure barr has report reportedly
tested negative
since gomer said back in june
that he didn't need to wear a mask
because he didn't have the virus
but said he would put a mask on if he
were to get infected
apparently he must have worn a mask at
some point
because here is video of louis gomer now
coveted positive
saying you know it might have been
wearing a mask
that gave me the virus
i can't help but wonder if by keeping a
mask on and keeping it
in place that if i might have uh
put uh some germs some fire some of the
virus
onto the mask and breathed it in i don't
know but
i got it we'll see what happens from
here but the reports of my demise
are uh very premature the mask
gave him the virus but he doesn't really
wear masks
if you can imagine this he was actually
scheduled to have some kind of birthday
barbecue fundraiser later in august
where donors were going to be given meet
and greet access to him
that crazy fox news host former judge
janine pirro was going to be there as a
special guest
no word on what's going on with that
event no word from fox news as to
whether
janine pirro would still be part of the
event if it were going to happen
but the mask wearing has become very
very partisan
at this point there's an axios ipsos
poll
from a few weeks ago which found that
two-thirds of democrats are wearing
masks
all the time when they're outside their
homes in public whereas only about half
that number 35 percent of republicans
are wearing masks
so it is a significant partisan divide
and that plays into remember my report
from earlier this week that
what has forced trump or pushed trump to
change his tone on coronavirus has been
that advisers went to him and said you
know
it's disproportionately our people
that's the word they used our people who
are getting this so it might be
bad from an election standpoint if this
continues now a few other things to show
you on this louis gomer went on sean
hannity's fox news program last night
and sean hannity was encouraging him to
take hydroxychloroquine and gomer said
yeah i'm taking it
and it was barely coherent he called it
hydrogeoxychlorine or something like
that take a look at this
you're uh a guy at c cedar sinai that
knows more about hydroxychloroquine than
anybody
have you thought about any of these have
you talked to your doctor about it any
thoughts on
it for yourself yes yes i have
and uh thanks for the discussion you've
had about it
you know you've talked about the one
study that said it won't affect it have
to be
withdrawn so yeah my doctor and i are
all in
and i got a text just before i came on
from my dear friend doctor that
just found out he had it and he said he
started
the dq regimen too so zeke corinthians
the hydrodox chlorine and that will
start
uh just in the next day or two yep so
thank you
so gohmert how is this real life gohmert
not only has no idea what he's taking he
actually says that
hannity's propaganda coverage of
hydroxychloroquine
at least partially influenced his desire
to take it
and then just one more little video for
you here is republican congressman kevin
mccarthy
calling louie gohmert congressman covet
and then correcting himself you want to
be able to trace it put him out and just
as uh
congressman kovitz congressman louis
gomer says that he doesn't have any
symptoms um
there could be other people like that so
what it what a world what a world that
we live in that's just perfect yeah
i think going forward i should refer to
louis gomer as congressman covid
now to get serious for a second um
herman cain went to donald trump's tulsa
oklahoma rally or tulsa as some people
say
and he was then diagnosed with
coronavirus he has now died
and there's every reason to believe that
herman cain former presidential
candidate and supporter of trump
caught the virus at trump's corona rally
in tulsa oklahoma he is dead now
okay so when we talk about this
i take no pleasure in herman cain dying
of coronavirus
even as it appears he caught it at an
optional rally that donald trump did
but we've just got to be serious and
realistic here when i talk to people in
other countries
people like louis gomer and these other
[ __ ] republicans they often come up
and sometimes people in other countries
just can't even understand what's going
on like how is it even possible for
people like gomer to get elected
how is it even real life that donald
trump is holding
a rally with 6 500 people indoors
in tulsa oklahoma which now as far as we
believe
led to the infection of herman cain and
subsequently the death like did trump
kill his friend
by having that rally is that is that a
crazy thing to say
how is it even possible that louis
gohmert is elected and
you really just have to understand the
united states to understand that i mean
understand the electorate in the texas
first congressional district
these are not ad hominems the texas
first congressional district where louis
gomer
is elected and the the district that he
represents
it's wildly right-wing trump got 72
percent of the vote in the first
district of texas in 2016.
mitt romney got 72 percent of the vote
in 2012.
mccain got 69 percent in 2008.
bush got 68 and 69 percent in 2000 and
2004.
this is a wildly right-wing area and
that
correlates at this point in time 2020 in
the united states
disproportionately with anti-science
beliefs
texas first district has even more
pronounced
texas problems texas is not a place with
particularly good health care
texas is not a place with particularly
good education it's
extra not good in the first district of
texas so
this is a complicated place they
tragically keep
electing louis gohmert and we're seeing
the consequences of this anti-science
ideology one of the things i'm going to
talk about at the start of tomorrow's
program
is that dr anthony fauci is now in the
unenviable position of having to beg and
plead with america to listen to science
and doctors
that's where we are meanwhile look at
what's happening in
new zealand look at what's happened in
south korea look at vietnam look at
you know greece place dramatically
different places culturally
geographically and economically
all have figured out how to deal with
the virus and this is what we're dealing
with it this is a tragedy and
you know the human de the human toll
party aside is my priority i don't want
anyone to get the virus or die
but there is one side that
has been the cause of these problems and
they must be held accountable if they
are not
what's to prevent them from doing
exactly the same thing next time
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an entire book
on your way home from work they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one into text or audio
that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect if you don't have
enough time
to do all the reading you want to do or
if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com slash pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video